[Music]
this is star talk i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist and
this is cosmic queries edition
which i love you love it too because you
all send us questions all the time and i
got with me nagin facade nagin welcome
back
hi
neil it's so good to be here welcome
back and you're still at it you're still
host of fake the nation one of the best
podcast titles ever
oh thank you so much yeah we're still
going hard at fake things fake donation
and
i think you even extended me an
invitation to return so i could check my
calendar yes let's see what happens
there and also
and on the cartoon network you you're
like
are you hosting a comedy festival do i
read that right
i'm a part of the adult swim comedy
festival and i'm just gonna be doing
some stand-up and it's gonna be really
fun cool cool and i told i always
thought it was odd that your profession
is defined by
whether you're standing or sitting where
is there sit down
[Laughter]
there's lay down comedy like what no
other profession are we all talking
about you know whether your legs are
straight or not this is weird
yeah this is one of the many uh
ways that comedians uh define themselves
it's just by various forms of ligament
and uh joint movement yeah i'm going to
be a stand-up astrophysicist there you
go
so the topic today is is brought to us
by the expertise of our guest oh my gosh
i i have a colleague
professor annette lee and that welcome
to star talk
happy to be here yeah yeah there you go
and and and so your expertise um well
you not only sort of have the
astrophysics chops but you also have a
deep
a deep appreciation for art
and
culture and not just any culture but
sort of indigenous cultures and their
historical relationship and current
relationship to the night sky
have i encapsulated that accurately
enough
yes and uh i also just want to say that
it's important for me to say um a little
introduction which is um mitakuye oyasen
all my relations everyone here in this
circle
i greet you with a good heart
my name is annette li i am mixed race
lakota
and
i am here on the land we call mini sota
makoche which is the land where the
water reflects the sky
money
minnesota you're a professor of
astronomy in the department of physics
at uh saint cloud state university and
that's right and where is that
about an hour north of minneapolis
okay
because saint cloud sounds like that's
not of this earth
well um so i find that to be a beautiful
tradition to recognize the relationship
of indigenous peoples to the land that
you're occupying in any given time and
place and i've i've been able to see
some of that and even participate in
some of it in recent years during
travels to
to australia and to new zealand and even
i was at a at an indigenously
designated part of the grand canyon
where we were filming part of cosmos and
it was just a it's such a beautiful
tradition so thanks for bringing that to
star talk
yeah so um with that i just want to say
that this is the original territory of
the dakota and later ojibwe people so
these are my communities and it's really
important to acknowledge both that
history and this present relationship
and i think the thing that you're
talking about is one of the most
important points because
like as astronomers it's all about like
looking at the stars and there are so
many amazing you know physical
properties and mysteries as well that we
do in the research area you know black
holes whatever
but
um in our indigenous knowledge systems
it's this idea that we are related to
earth and sky and we even in lakota have
a word for it it's kippemany and company
is as it is above it is below so it has
to do with everything in the sky is
reflected or mirrored on the earth and
most importantly we are a part of that
because we come from the stars we we
carry earth and sky within us as our
bones are made of earth our physical
atoms and then our spirits come from the
stars so this idea of earth and sky and
our participation
is embedded in in so much of what we're
talking about here it's it's just uh not
just in lakota and first nations uh
teachings but also
throughout all indigenous peoples so
when you said you were in maori
territory or in australia aboriginal
lands it's exactly that i've even heard
this concept is in the bible
so it's like throughout human history
and throughout time this idea that
there's this relationship between the
above and below and our participation
that's the key part
our participation in this cosmic
mirroring so back to you
that's our show right there we're done
there's nothing you and i could say
let's go have a beer now because this
this
the earth the sky we're part of it it's
part of us
we're done
we should just shut up
i feel like i feel like i just took
ketamine you know what i mean just while
she was speaking it was just transported
into another dimension
also annette you're really blowing my
mind because i thought the first person
to like look at the stars and and notice
some stuff was some white guy in europe
so you're telling me that might not be
accurate from my teachings in elementary
school
so negan you can add a chapter to your
how to make white people laugh tell them
no you weren't the first
apparently not the first guys isn't that
hilarious you thought you were the first
and you weren't
so annette what does it mean precisely
when i learned that you were director
and founder of native sky watchers what
is that
so um back in 2007 i started an
organization where indigenous lead
grassroots
and it's all about
revitalizing our indigenous connection
to the sky which is sky and earth and
our participation in it
and it started out with just our local
ojibwe and dakota lakota
community
knowledge holders and elders and it was
actually fueled by this amazing thing so
i'm also a planetarium director
and um
i would be doing planetarium shows and
just by nature i'd be pointing out like
well there's leo the lion but there's
also the ojibwe lion mushi baju and i'd
be like isn't it cool that the greek
lion's head is the ojibwe lion's tail
like what are the chances that anyone
would see a lion anyways in that pattern
of stars that looks like a backwards
question mark so i was pointing out
these um ojibwe um and dakota lakota
connections are you just being polite
saying that it's their tail rather than
it's the
it's their butt
is called the great panther but it's
also called curly tail and okay
obviously like the cat the mountain lion
so they just did turn their head into a
butt it's actually they have it's the
tail it's a really important part
there's all these stories about it
anyway so but now we know where neal's
head is
you can bring that in i have young kids
that are boys so they're always talking
about button for farts
i was in the planetarium and i'm just
you know in the element you know you're
in the dark you're feeling the magic of
the planetarium and pointing out these
stars and then afterwards this teacher
um she was from a nearby reservation so
clearly you know at least half her class
was visibly native and she ran up to me
after the show was like where did you
get this how do you find how how do i
get any resources how do i find out
anything about this there's nothing
available and yet she told me
the minnesota state science standards
had had um one of their benchmarks was
to bring in how um people from all
cultures have participated in science
particularly plucking right there right
exactly and so then with some nasa
support uh we were able to do our first
series of educator workshops and we
created star maps um and then curriculum
and planospheres and videos
nasa is very good at funding programs
that train educators because that's the
greatest leverage point you have in the
in the whole system of learning so it's
really delighted to hear that they they
took a role in this as well so sorry
interrupted go on oh well no it was
great because at the time embarrassingly
i didn't even know about these state
standards um and so when she told me
this i said well this is what i do this
is my community this is my work and you
know come to the workshop and and so
really it was kind of like that
um what do you call that that perfect
moment like being the perfect place per
perfect person in the perfect place the
planets align
[Laughter]
and that's where we started and then
since then um
make it clear so negan because she's an
actual astrophysicist she knows the
planet's aligning is a meaningless
reference so i had to like pry it out of
her and make her say it okay i didn't
want to say it oh i see okay okay that
was astrophysicist inside jokes yeah
that's a subtext there she was not going
to say it until i made her say it okay
i'm happy to step outside the box no
problem anytime
so yeah we just kind of went on from
there and now it's exploded um with we
have international partners and
relationships and not just our ojibwe
like local ojibwe and dakota lakota but
we do that as well as national work we
work right now we have a cohort for with
hawaiian at the volcano school um uh
with maya with
um african-american
uh
down in mexico the comcac um it goes on
and on the
australian aboriginal i have maori
collaborators so we are so excited to be
global yep excellent so so what started
as just a simple
encounter became now this movement which
i think is is brilliant and beautiful so
now i noticed from your resume you also
have an mfa
in uh fine arts is that correct
yes definitely
so so how does that fall into your your
your your your efforts here did you
criticize the drawings of constellations
i could do better
i could do better than stick figures
i do have a really high bar when it
comes to visuals but um where it comes
together is that i have been a
practicing visual artist for
i mean i can remember
being in art shows and and winning
awards for art in in grade school
um i've always loved art but just like
i've always loved math and uh astronomy
people ask me what came first and i said
well that you know you could say both
because i was just born like this like i
always love the stars i always love
sitting under the stars and i always
loved like the analytics the math doing
math and i always in science and i've
always loved doing art and so basically
to me where it comes together is
we've been doing a tremendous amount
of video project productions and digital
media
and this is really taking off because as
with kovid
we got another nasa grant and this
project was called two-eyed seeing and
this was just last year
and let me explain this is called
edowaptamonk edo optimunk is the mikama
word for two-eyed seeing and this comes
from my colleagues
over in nova scotia carol and awkwood
and her elders
and basically it means to see with the
best in one eye
with the indigenous way of knowing
and to see with the best in the other
eye
the western science way of knowing
but the key part to see with both eyes
for the benefit of all
they call it the gift of multiple
perspectives
i have an astigmatism in one eye where
does that look no no we leave you out
you're not invited to that party
that means it's like slightly
off-centered i think there's a place for
that because everyone should be slightly
off-centered well wait no no [ __ ] the
world is messed up enough we can't have
you and your astigmatism defining
anything that comes out of europe yeah
no i i would be dr i'm the one
drawing those stick figures
well that's another beautiful concept
thanks for sharing that i just want to
remind people this is a cosmic queries
and we took this topic out to
our patreon members who get exclusive
access to this question and answer
session so and they get their questions
everyone gets to hear it but they get to
ask the questions so negine what you
have a first question for her yes uh
daniel kolikowski who's a fellow
minnesotan uh says i'm wondering what
your views are on the current state of
light pollution around the world and any
negative impacts it has on people's
feelings and perceptions about the night
sky
oh well that's a big topic let us take a
break and when we come back we're going
to find out uh
we're going to find out what a net has
to say about pollution because in
astronomy
light pollution is
equivalent in the damage that it does to
our access to the universe as air
pollution is in its damage to our lungs
is that too far did i go too far on that
dude guys not at all not at all not far
enough
not far enough see
nikki what can we do what are we going
to do
this is her show she's going to be
[Laughter]
all right now we're going to come we're
going to come right back to you right
after this break
we're back star talk cosmic queries
we're talking about what the universe
looks like to indigenous peoples
and it looks a little different from
what you've probably been taught in
school and we've got one of the world's
experts on that uh professor annette lee
and saint cloud so no gain uh we left
off with a question about light
pollution and who's that from again
that's right daniel kolakowski was
asking um about your views on the
current state of light pollution around
the world and if there's any negative
impacts on people's feelings and
perceptions about the nights what do you
have in it
so we are with light pollution um i'm
gonna start there i'm gonna say yes i am
very concerned about light pollution
i've done a lot of work with the
international dark sky association
and the idea is that
from an indigenous uh
practice and way of life
uh the sky in our connection with the
sky
it's an essential it's not an option
it's not an accessory
it's uh the place where we come from the
stars are not just
physical
distant abstract balls of plasma or gas
those are our relatives our oldest
living relatives
and you know we even have in lakota
there's teachings that the the stars are
the breath of the spirits you know so
it's not it's about like a family
reunion it's blocking that level of
connection
and i want to say that so much of my
work it does have to do with the crisis
and stem education and bringing in more
pathways for our black and brown
indigenous students but it's also about
wellness
because we we have a problem right
if students don't have
a reason for living if they're in so
much pain and crisis and trauma that
they're literally
giving up on life and i'm talking about
the youth suicide statistics which are
sky high here in minnesota no no pun
intended but the the rate is like three
times higher for our native youth and
you know these are my kids right
um and this is
our our new youth suicide rate is higher
in minnesota for native kids than it is
um
across the nation for native kids it's
really high
there's disparities in the education
system minnesota is always first second
or third in the disparity and graduation
rates between majority kids and minority
kids so back to the pollution you know
you thought it was about dis pollution
but it's all connected and the idea is
that we have this teaching where we come
from the stars
and this
moment of our lifetime is just a blink
we're here in our material form you know
but our original form is a spiritual
form from the stars
and so we come here with purpose
right is is it only light pollution
because suppose nagin does a stand-up
thing and it comes on at night and i'm
watching her instead of going out and
looking up in the sky isn't every
distraction that
exists in modern living that distracts
us in the evening
isn't that tan amount to light pollution
you know we have hbo and disney plus and
and netflix and all these things i come
home
and my first thought is let me binge
something or let me watch a movie or let
me watch nagin
doing a stand-up not a sit-down a
stand-up
aren't aren't you also competing with
all the rest of these cultural forces
yes absolutely we we are very distracted
we have very short attention spans we're
looking for the next fun thing but the
there's something really important and
fundamental about our connection to the
stars um and that there should be a
place for that there should be a kind of
protection for that i know that with the
international dark sky association there
we've you know created this uh
protection protected areas because we
talk about the extinction like the night
sky is going extinct and so you know
here in minnesota it's a luxury because
we can drive you know five ten minutes
and really see dark skies we can really
see
uh the andromeda galaxy we could really
see the northern lights right i mean
you're in new york city wow i really
feel bad for you
we have a planetarium right
yeah we just we just we just uh huddled
together
in the planetarium dome and put up the
fake aurora and the fake uh that's what
don't forget
make you feel at home yeah yeah
can i just say in defense of myself
though that my stand-up is not the enemy
of the cosmos if anything it's squid
game
so let's just like you know
note where popular culture is right now
come on just blame something else
instead of yourself okay fine but you
know annette i actually i grew up in the
desert of southern california in a town
called palm springs and they have very
strict light pollution laws so i live in
new york city now where in my estimation
we don't have stars
um but in palm springs we have a ton of
stars i grew up with uh seeing a lot of
scars be stars because they were very
serious about light pollution with your
astigmatism very clearly
and i'd often see them there's
there's two there's two of everything if
you look at it through my through my
eyes okay so jay hunt asks i was
wondering how indigenous tribes
constellations identification and sky
tracking has changed over the centuries
what are some of the more famous
constellations that have made it into
the modern lexicon oh interesting so the
changes over the ages i think one of the
biggest things to say about that is the
idea of
loss
we've lost a lot of our star knowledge
in our cultural knowledge in our
languages because of colonization
in the star maps that we created you
know working with elders and other
primary sources
there's a lot of like blank spaces
and um my in a new elder wilford buck
he talks about the idea that
um you know
before colonization that map would have
been filled up just like what we think
of now as the greek map it would have
been dense you know every single star
and even the dimmer stars there's
constellations but now we look at our
constellations and there's there's some
spaces
and that's part of that loss so i think
you're bumming
well it's not all bad but because you
know it's not all gone it's not too far
gone we have hope we have we still have
you know wilford says you know it would
be like we still have that 15 percent
left and we're rebuilding it you know
but the 85 percent was lost due to
colonization
so
anyways i think that's like what comes
to my mind in just you know a really
honest way
that even though a lot of people in
history class and all we learned that
colonization you know back in the 1400s
the 1500s the first most important thing
is that we are still living
living in the wake of that history and
that event so where we are today has
everything to do with what happened you
know 500 years ago there's there's no
denying that i think it's extremely
important to acknowledge that
so that's why we're trying to build it
back
um i'm working right now with migama um
elders and knowledge holders and we're
in the process of creating their star
map
so like i said there's a lot of hope
here too i don't want to be like all
negative but also we have to be honest
you know that that this is happening and
it's a part of where we are today
so back to the question one of the
things i go to is the big dipper because
the big dipper is so popular you know
it's something that everyone in here in
the northern hemisphere kind of knows
those uh seven bright stars
and so like for example um we think of
ursa major um through the so-called
greek um uh constellations or asterisms
the nicknames for the stars you know the
big dipper
and um we also have a lot of uh
teachings there like one from the
internew is a bear as well but it faces
in the opposite direction so just like i
was saying like with the curly tail and
the ojibwe mountain lion we have the
same lion with the greek where the greek
leo the line is we have other teachings
with the bear
um and the bearer for us is more to do
with
um like a medicine
um and also the bear has to do with um
it's one of the only animals that's
two-legged
so there's a really important story that
has to do with like people because we're
two-legged right so there's like the
winged ones the ones that crawl there's
the four-legged you know like mammals
and you know dogs and
but then there's a two-legged and so
we're the two-legged but see the bear is
kind of one of those animals that's also
sometimes two-legged but this is the key
point
the
the two-legged represent and bring
wisdom
so
the bearer has wisdom and we as humans
have wisdom so that's kind of like what
we bring like to the whole circle
and i think that's really important
because
it's because we have our wisdom and we
have our strong critical minds that we
can get out of um you know these uh
situations that we're in right now that
there is so much hope you know that we
can create a better future and that's
why we're here talking about it right so
ultimately it is totally an optimistic
and um let's let's create something
better for
our kids you know let's let's address
some of the crisis yeah
you see this i have a stupid observation
to share with you if you go to circus
acts and you see dogs performing the dog
that is typically walking on two legs
more than other breeds of dogs is the
poodle you ever notice that that the
poodle is walking on its two hind legs
more often than other
breeds of dogs and they say that the
poodle is the smartest among the dogs so
you were talking about wisdom among the
two-legged walkers i just was wondering
i haven't had any interaction with
poodles or
circus like that but i think that's a
brilliant connection wow poodles do not
chase their tail that is this is a non
thing for poodles for example my
my thought about the the bears is that
there are a crossover category and the
two-legged and the four-legged sort of
like when justin bieber started singing
in spanish and he became a crossover
that's that's that's probably a better
analogy than my poodle
although i would say neil we both sort
of failed yeah and one other thing uh
negan maybe you don't know this but
the greek rendering of ursa major is a
big chubby bear with a big bushy tail
but bears don't have tails they don't
have big bushy tails so it's it's it's
an anatomically forced addition to the
species simply because they were
connecting the dots
oh it's like early animation
you know they were just like
exaggerating making it up yeah i mean
they do have tails but they're nubby
stubby things that are barely even uh
visible in the dense density of their
hair
so yeah annette what do you
what do the natives do with with the
bear's existence or non-existence of a
tail um you know that's a good question
i haven't heard any you know cute
stories about the um i know in the
planetarium there's a typical story
about how the bear
uh got the lake its tail frozen in the
lake
i think it was given some food and it
turned around it got a fish out of the
lake and then
it took too long to eat it and the tail
froze in the lake and then it stepped
away and the tail broke off
and so the early bears have tails but
the later ones don't and so and that's a
really tall tale yes a zeus came um
swooping down to save the bears from
hera and so he grabbed the bears by the
only thing he could their short tails
and swung them around to get enough
momentum to
you know whiz them up into the cosmos
and then that stretched out their tail
so anyways those are those silly
planetarium
um tales that we tell about the bears
tales um also like an early version of
like bear weight watchers or something
what i was gonna say here is that many
of those constellations that we think of
as the greek mainstream type
constellations actually were borrowed
from the babylonians
so um you probably know that neil i
don't know if you've come across that
but especially the babylonians are deep
in there and somehow
there's a there's some kind of
smokescreen where the real
influence of that of
ancient you know the ancient peoples of
babylon don't make it through and we
just it stops at greece but half of that
is that's right that's right from my
understanding it has to do with you know
the the greeks the babylonians and the
egyptians right there along the
mediterranean sea so there was a lot of
you know sharing and mixing and warring
and everything um but yeah you're right
that it actually ended up just being
labeled now we think of oh that comes
from the greek tradition but there's so
much more to the story um and i think i
think the babylonians gave us base 60
which is what which is uh the whole
foundation
yeah 60 seconds uh 60 minutes in an hour
and then also the egyptians brought in
the idea of the 12
the 12-hour days
with the sun going across and then down
into the underworld so there's a lot of
like cultural stories and and knowledges
here embedded even in just we can just
scratch the surface
and then there's it's so much more
interesting than you know what we
originally think of it's just coming
from one culture yeah of course i think
the egyptians also gave us beer so you
could get drunk and look at stars
just get credit where credit is due okay
so
matt hairfield um has a question that
requires a little bit of visualization
if the moon was not tidally locked with
the earth and instead rotated at some
observable rate making it more obviously
a three-dimensional object how do you
think that would have changed the way
ancient humans perceive the cosmos
so that implies that people thought the
moon was just a flat disc
um
because it always just showed one side i
hadn't thought about that annette what
what does your research tell you about
the moon
well that's a deep question let me think
well the moon i guess off the top of my
head the thing is i
i don't feel that it would change a
great deal
um the indigenous
teachings that i'm familiar with and you
know i can't speak for everyone
obviously but
because the the teachings um with the
moon it's all about relationships
and in a way it doesn't matter like it's
almost like that's like a technicality
like you know if it's 2d or 3d or
whatever i mean okay yeah that's cool
that's interesting but that's more like
a geometrical fact i think what's more
important is that the grandmother
moon as seen as a relative a close
relative as helping us
as connected with
time keeping and connected with what we
call turtle island so here in north
america you know this is turtle island
there's a lot of stories
about
this being connected with the turtle and
the turtle has 28 large sections on the
back so that's connected with the moon
and so the turtle also is important
having to do with like
the beginning of life which also
connects with the moon you know we think
the idea of having a large moon close in
was helpful for
the you know helping to like nurture
life um and also that it created the
tides so the tides helped the the
life that was existing on the earth for
so long only in the ocean came out of
the ocean onto the land right and it
just happened more recently but this has
had to do with the the tides and the
moon is one of the main sources of the
tides so these are like deeper
connections that have to do with the
turtle the moon the life on earth and i
think that that is a way
more important the moon also has to do
with heartbeat um because of the
changing phases of light and darks makes
if you watch it in fast motion it feels
and looks just like a heartbeat
so it has to do with uh our our human
heartbeat too
i would add that it would be hard to
explain a flat disc
model
given the curve of the shadowing as the
moon goes through its crescent phase
you know spheres will give you that
that kind of light pattern on it um not
flat discs so
um yeah interesting interesting there we
got to take another break
and when we do
and that with your permission can we go
into a lightning round
uh in
that means you have to answer questions
in five seconds
it enables us to get through more
questions than we otherwise would
because it's quite luxurious to give the
full hammer of your breadth of knowledge
to each of these questions okay
lightning yeah i'm going with the flow
you think you can have it i don't know
i've never done lightning yeah yeah it's
it's it's it's different
and again you have lightning questions
lined up
oh yeah okay all right when we come back
the game will send lightning bolts in a
net direction on star talk cosmic
queries
we're back star talk cosmic queries
we're talking about what the sky looks
like to people who are not white
do i characterize that correctly we have
a special guest here who is a world
expert on
this very topic annette lee from saint
cloud university just north of
minneapolis so we're in the middle of
some cosmic queries with her and the
game facade is now going to take us into
the lightning rod with her but before we
do that just because this is our last
segment nagin tell us how we find you on
social on social media
ooh you can find me at naginfarsad on
instagram on twitter even on tick tock
oh yeah oh yeah guys don't worry i don't
dance on okay all right i've saved you
from that and how about annette how do
we find you on the in the social
universe
i don't even know what tic tac is so
um
[Laughter]
uh yeah just try email native
nativeskywatchers gmail.com oh okay all
right is there a website associated yeah
the website the website
nativeskywatchers.org
nativeskywatchers.com
oh we got lots of cool projects
that will make up for not being on
instagram and twitter that's where we'll
find your all your activities very
excellent okay negan throw some
lightning bolts at a net see how many of
these questions we can get okay
here we go donna palmieri asks are there
any astronomical discoveries made by
western scientists that indigenous
people of north america had already
known so when it was announced the
indigenous community was like oh yeah we
knew that a while ago where have you
been okay
so that's a that's a yes or no i would
say yes we're there yes and and what
exactly i mean so lightning round you
can take 10 seconds to answer the
question
yeah in one second
what's the best example of this okay
here i'm just going to tell you my
example that comes to mind in five
seconds is that
um the everyone well some people notice
the sun how it goes from east to west
and higher or lower and there's a
beautiful pattern that with the sun if
you watch it throughout the year
but um
what about the moon did you ever notice
the moon has a pattern
of where it rises where it sets how low
how high
and so this moon um rising and setting
pattern is a really another beautiful
dance that is done in relation to the
sun well so anyways um it's kind of
complicated but basically i remember
learning about it and then one day i was
talking to an ojibwe elder and he was
like oh yeah
um short shadows uh walking home
snowshoeing
short
short shadows so what he was talking
about is in the middle of winter when
they're snowshoeing across a frozen lake
okay like up in canada
and in the at midnight the moon's out
but the moon has a really high path
across the sky
in the middle of winter because it's
opposite the sun so
the sun is low in the winter the moon is
really high are you still with me
all the air
and the moon is really high so when
you're walking on your snowshoes across
a frozen lake and it's 40 below
then there's gonna be a really short
shadow because the moon is basically
directly overhead or closer
so something that most like whatever
mainstream or western sciences
folks don't even know about the path of
the moon and the height of the moon in a
seasonal pattern
it's not necessarily even taught in
typical astro 101 classes or you know
any level but this was like a everyday
common like you know yeah like duh yeah
short shadows um in the winter and this
is the benefit of simply paying
attention to what's going on in the sky
and what's going on around you right
right okay so now we have to dock 90
seconds from your next question
okay
here we go
i only said i would give it a try okay
give her another one
slap it with another one robert robert
bragger asks how is ed um sorry robert
bratcher asks how has science education
changed over the last decade and how
will it continue to change to keep
children and teens interested and what
they're learning furthering their thirst
for scientific discovery in all aspects
of the science fields
so how has it changed okay so it's
changed by what what used to be the
lecture model the standard model as the
teachers like all knowing and the
students as blank slates well all the
research shows that doesn't work right
and so this idea of active learning and
then my research and other folks in the
area of astronomy education research the
idea that we can bring culture and our
humanity back into learning science and
we can have students learn more science
and be more engaged and then the other
ideas this idea of like stem identity
and science identity that it's not
enough just to know the facts or to be
good enough to know the facts because we
have half of those kids are dropping out
at the college level out of stem
and what we need to do is to create a
welcome you say dropping out you mean
switching majors they're switchers
they're switchers
we have a recruitment problem and then
on top of that we have a retention
problem um because they're switching
even the a and b students are switching
out of stem and so we talk about the
psychology a lot of the research now in
stem education has to do with the
psychology like hey well why would they
be dropping out it's because they don't
feel a sense of community it's because
they don't see themselves as a stem
professional and so creating
opportunities in professional uh
pathways where they can be like rubbing
elbows with nasa scientists or you know
world-class working on work world-class
telescopes at the high school or even
elementary level so it's becoming more
of a holistic experience as an educator
and as a student
in a word holistic and also um
bringing in more of our humanity like
that we don't have if we're going to do
science we don't have to be robots we
don't have to be machines i mean we can
we can multitask right najin
we're good at multitasking
so we can we don't have to like pretend
like we don't have hearts or we're not
you know we don't have bias we could
just say yeah but we're going to
practice the methods of science as best
we can but still admit that we're still
human beings and there's still culture
happening as a part of this
got it got it all right
you still failed the 10 second rule
okay this next one you have to say a
negative three seconds let's see how you
do that
um
robert weaver asks what is your favorite
observation of the night sky that can be
seen without the assistance of a
telescope
i like that one oh i love looking at the
night sky without a telescope though
there's so many how many how am i gonna
fit this in a negative three seconds no
you're just gonna give the best thing
uh the pleiades um the pleiades is known
as the bhaganagizik try to say that
bhaga nagisik that's a
ojibwe word for um the hole in the sky
so it's a kind of a doorway a
star doorway between the the physical
plane and the spiritual plane bhaganagik
um so i can just leave you hanging there
but i love to see the pleiades and i'm
sure you know i have aboriginal art in
australia oh yeah we've looked i looked
at a lot of what they portrayed and the
pleiades are in practically every
illustration and maori and maori yeah
throughout human history that's probably
the number one go-to where all the
cultures have some amazing teachings
related to the pleiades and then when
you i love to look to the side and then
you can use your averted vision your uh
your rods instead of your cones and then
you see it just pop you have to do that
right najin you've done that right
she's
[Music]
it doesn't matter if your eyes off
center you can you can still do it
because you just look instead of looking
directly at it you look to the side and
you're using your rods instead of your
cones and it just gets brighter it's
total magic you gotta try i feel i feel
so uh i feel so naked that you you're
referring to my rods and cones
i feel bonded with you because i think
this is a little bit of an r-rated
podcast suddenly
i think i have that too a little bit in
one eye so i don't i don't feel like
that's a deal breaker at all there's so
much magic and cool stuff when we look
at the sky you know and that's one of
the things i love you can do it with the
andromeda galaxy too
excellent in fact just just a bit more
formal about that the andromeda galaxy
is the single farthest object visible to
the unaided human eye
in the sky then it's two million light
years away so it's the farthest object
okay here we go adventurer asks uh
please
is that allowed
adventure spelled with a y instead of an
e
um
please tell me your thoughts on the
commonalities and differences in
cosmology astrology astrophysics and
astronomy and yes line dancers love star
talk too we even have a line dance
called mars needs women
okay
answer that in five seconds
yeah the commonalities and differences
between all of these things
well you know i'm gonna i'm gonna recast
that question
i'm just going to recast it
and that you've studied cultures
indigenous cultures that are hugely
geographically separated presumably they
each have an origin story for the
universe or for their culture for people
or for the earth
is there something that you can cite
that they all have in common
and something that is especially
different about them
um okay one thing that's common is the
idea that
um
the earth is very old and that humans
are very new
and that there's like this been
different versions of life on earth like
in science we have just you know the
here was humanity you know evolution
right but in indigenous knowledges
there's
basically the story is a lot more
interesting and complex
that there were different versions of
um humans being on earth and then
destruction happening um where it is it
started anew
like in lakota like i was talking about
the bear um the motto is the bear and
this idea that humans
humans kind of got out of balance and
then the earth did this like resetting
where it shook and there was disaster
and flooding and fires and then we got
another chance and so this is our second
chance so anyways it's the idea that the
earth is much older and much more to the
story than just one
one version of humanity okay this is the
short answer cool and i guess the
biblical correspondence to that would be
noah's flood because yeah before that
and after it and so there's you know
anti-diluvian and post-illuvian
stories
about humans
yeah so there's a lot of teachings i can
think of too like it has to do with you
know before we got to the time we're in
now and and like the relationship
between humans and animals like one
thing that's really cool is the idea
that humans and animals could talk to
each other
um not in the non-verbal language like
we think of today like horse whispering
or something like that but like they
literally talk to each other but then
things got out of balance and things got
too chaotic and so then there was this
period of like destruction and then
started anew with like new um new rules
and regulations and order my pomeranian
and i had a really nice chat this
morning so uh it was mostly about treats
um but i feel like he still does
sometimes you have a pomegranate
let your elders know i have a pumpkin
you never told me that okay
oh yeah we'd have a different
relationship
[Laughter]
that's a small dog right yes it's so
it's more hair than body and it's about
this it's no bigger than like
half of a basketball
and
i have one of the larger ones he's dead
i do the pomeranian is embarrassingly
cute
that's it's it's just it's too it's no
animal should be that cute and it is and
it knows it and so it's it's some i just
think if i were a wolf
i would just feel so bad that they took
my dna and made that thing out of it
if i if i looked into the night sky i
think i would see many pomeranians like
i would probably mostly see pomeranians
in the night sky that's already amazing
right
yeah neil talked about a poodle and
again talked about a pomeranian all
right yeah exactly
wolf dog see that's a little better
that's a little more
true to the roots
let's slip in one more question okay one
more question i really love this
question georgetowner asks how did the
indigenous peoples of north america
create kivas that capture the rising sun
on the spring and fall equinox an
example being chaco canyon in new mexico
somebody's been around somebody's doing
some homework all right and that what
what's what do you have to say about
that holy smokes well like down in the
southwest those are my collaborators
nancy maryboy and david begay they are
the go-to to talk to they're um navajo
dna and they can talk about the pueblo
and the dna connections and the chaco
canyon i mean by the way so in your in
your website the the skywatcher website
um do we have reference to all of your
other collaborators there and some of
their work as well
yeah yeah you can see that in the two
eyed seeing project you can see the
video recordings live stream and we had
our indigenous knowledge holders working
with students indigenous students and
their teachers and they created content
related to you know this indigenous
astronomy and nasa science and what was
most meaningful to them so i would
highly recommend you go and and check
that out you might spend a little more
time than you were thinking in that
because there's always should be content
if you did if you did the site right
that's what should be happening to
people all right they'll get lost in it
lost in a very good way so we've got to
call it quits there
ned it's been great to have you on this
and and to meet a fellow planetarian
and
uh we'll find some other excuse to get
you back on and we'll talk planetarium
smack we'll just don't forget
always good to have you i'm going to
look for you so much
on the cartoon network and
yes i look forward to that so uh again
thanks again i i enjoyed this
this show there's so much to learn and
know about peoples of the world that
aren't always the ones
that are in your face telling you what
they think you should know it takes a
little effort and it's richly rewarded
and i'm glad we have uh folks
and that folks like you who are just in
there
getting the job done and taking names so
thanks for what you do what you bring to
the world and for being a guest on star
talk
i'm neil degrasse tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist and as always i
did you
to keep looking up
[Music]